[Music]
on this Sunday night Mother's Day
overshadowed by Mother Nature
record-breaking heat baking BC and
fueling even more wildfires in Alberta
forcing thousands to flee our town is
they said in the we won't be going home
in the foreseeable future is there any
relief in sight
is this the end of erdogan
[Applause]
turkey's long-time powerful president
faces his toughest political fight we've
got the latest election results
breast cancer concerns upwards of 400
avoidable deaths
every year the new U.S research sparking
calls for Canada to start screening
sooner
plus Mother's Day in morning it's hard
enough losing your mother Canada's
largest cemetery closed for months from
a labor strike opens its gates to
frustrated families
global national with para Nasser
reporting tonight Jeff Semple
good evening and thank you for joining
us we begin tonight with the wildfires
burning relentlessly in Alberta more
people were ordered to leave their homes
overnight and the number forced to
escape is only expected to rise as those
hot dry conditions cover the province
there appears to be no end in sight
across Alberta tonight there are 90
wildfires burning a quarter are out of
control more than 19 thousand people
have been ordered out of their homes and
there's no word on when they will be
able to return Alberta officials
provided an update late today
for those who are in a community that's
on an evacuation alert
I cannot stress strongly enough the need
for residents to be prepared in case
there is an urgent need to evacuate
things can change quickly and in
evacuation order may be issued with
little warning
right now the fire danger is considered
extreme and is poised to get worse
what's known as a heat Dome is hitting
this weekend that's when the heat is
higher than the relative humidity
causing temperatures to climb well above
30 degrees in some areas Marnie blunt is
in Fox Creek where an evacuation order
has been expanded Marnie Jeff as you can
see behind me the community of Fox Creek
is closed residents have been forced to
leave their homes unsure of when they'll
be able to return as the Wildfire
continues to burn out of control growing
to now more than 25 000 hectares in size
massive wall of smoke and Flames
backdrops the community of Fox Creek
Alberta
Alberta Wildfire Crews working
relentlessly to keep the fire at Bay
fighting the Flames alongside heli
attack Crews from Oregon and Cypress
Hills and a pre-suppression crew from
Quebec the town evacuated an eerily
quiet with a wildfire on its doorstep
many forced to flee to the nearby
community of White Court living away
from home yeah a week later is it's
getting tiresome I know we're away from
home and everybody's stressed but as
long as everybody is you know safe is
the main thing for me I mean we're all
wondering whether we're going to have
homes to go to or not
an evacuation Center has been set up
helping those newly homeless with
supports and donations for items they
may need and providing a place for
families to gather away from their hotel
rooms it's been interesting
um
it's been stressful our town is they
said in the we won't be going home in
the foreseeable future so I don't know
what that means but I'm hoping Within
a nice a week or so the mayor of
Whitecourt says they've supported over
1600 Wildfire evacuees including some
from other communities we're just trying
to make it take some stress out of
people's lives we know how stressful
this is and we're starting to make it
better
event can we say they're grateful for
the sense of community they've received
it's it's overwhelming it's uh you know
it's a very sense of community you know
what I mean wonderful neighbors it's
just overwhelming how they've come
together and and helped us now behind
the community bulldozers are working to
build fire guards to prevent the
Wildfire from coming even closer which
is now about 15 kilometers Northeast of
Fox Creek and another 14 kilometers
southeast of the community of little
Smokey Jeff all right thanks Marnie
and those summer-like temperatures are
baking not only Alberta but also BC that
province is being hit with a heat wave a
special weather statement is now in
place temperatures are 10 to 15 degrees
above normal for mid-may breaking
records and sparking wildfires flooding
and heat related illness here's
Catherine urquhart
across British Columbia residents are
dealing with a record-breaking Heat Wave
It's really
hot it's pretty hot we're glad that we
brought umbrellas and refreshments in
Latin it was 34.1 degrees Saturday
making it Canada's hot spot and smashing
a previous record of 29.6 set in 2012.
not welcome news in a community that
burned to the ground in 2021 amid
extreme heat and there were dozens of
other records first heat wave of the
season and temperature soaring 10 and up
to 15 degrees above the average for this
time of the year temperatures records
fell yesterday and we'll see more
falling today and likely and towards our
Monday
with several days of heat still ahead
warnings are being issued for those most
vulnerable to heat exhaustion and heat
stroke we know that people who are at
high risk of heat related illness don't
always realize when their bodies are
getting too hot or their space is
getting too hot and that's why I really
encourage people to check on their
friends and neighbors sunny skies are
always a draw for outdoor adventurers
many of whom head up to the mountains
for those often tasked with rescuing
them there was this piece of advice you
need to make sure you're hydrated before
your hike make sure you have lots of
water with you put some nun tablets or
Gatorade into that as well so you get
some electrolytes out of it and then the
other really important factor and we're
seeing this today is you need to have
sunscreen clearly many are enjoying this
unexpected heat wave in BC wear a hat
there's lots of sunscreen
with everyone
urged to do so safely
Catherine urquhart Global News Vancouver
turning to Europe now where the
Ukrainian president was in Germany
meeting with Chancellor Olaf Schultz
it's Vladimir zielinski's latest stop on
his European tour to push allies for
faster delivery of weapons for Ukraine's
defense the German government has
pledged the largest Aid package to
Ukraine since Russia's Invasion 15
months ago as Kiev prepares for a major
counter-offensive tariya isri reports
Ukrainian president volada
Grand reception
German Chancellor
Chancellor welcomed him to Berlin with
military honors
how to become in Berlin this is
zelenski's first trip to the country
since Russia's invasion of Ukraine and
he will be returning home with a big get
Germany pledged nearly 3 billion euros
for weapons and equipment the largest
military aid package since the conflict
began
Ukraine has our full support says Shoals
condemning the Russian invasion as an
imperialistic attack at the onset of the
war Berlin was reluctant to arm Ukraine
but has since become one of the biggest
suppliers of military hardware like
leopard tanks Germany has worked very
hard to overcome its image as a
militaristic aggressive country since
World War II but the Ukrainian president
did not walk away with everything he
wanted they would love to be getting
warplanes from Germany that's what
they're really asking for again
zelenski's Outreach to three European
powers Germany Italy and France comes as
Ukraine prepares for a widely
anticipated counter-offensive in bakmut
the big question is does Ukraine have
now the capacity to do what Russia no
longer has the capacity zelenski told
reporters in Germany Ukraine is almost
ready for victory but he faced questions
about conversations he may have had
behind closed doors according to the
Washington Post leaked intelligence
documents shows zelenski suggested
Ukraine conduct strikes in Russia
something zielinski dismissed saying
Ukraine does not have the time or
resources that has been kind of a red
line if Ukraine were to hit Russian
territories or perhaps then that would
put the war on a different level
zelenski insists
coming counter-offensive is about
liberating Russian occupied areas in
Crane and
Russian territory tariya isri Global
News Ottawa
meanwhile in Belarus the health of
President Alexander lukashenko is in
doubt after he failed to appear at
multiple events today lukashenko was
absent from belarus's national flag day
he usually gives a speech during the
annual celebration but this year his
prime minister spoke on his behalf the
Belarusian Leader's last public
appearance was on May 9 for Russia's
Victory Day Parade where he left early
and missed a state lunch with his close
Ally Russian President Vladimir Putin
well the polls are now closed in Turkey
which held its presidential elections
today widely seen as the country's most
important vote in decades and at this
point the result appears too close to
call and could be heading for a runoff
raychip tayyip erdogan has been in power
for 20 years but faces a growing
opposition led by Challenger Kemal
kalichdarulu our Europe correspondent
Redmond Shannon is tracking that vote
for us from London and he joins us now
so Revan what's the latest from the
results
well Jeff it looks like most of the
votes have now been counted on both
state-run media and opposition leading
media say that the incumbent president
ratchet tayab erdogan leads his main
Challenger Kamal khilichtaralu by about
four to five percent but it's possible
neither man will reach the 50 threshold
to win today
so this comes after one of the most
difficult years in modern history for
turkey
the first results released by state-run
media suggested that turkey's 64 million
voters had comfortably decided to stick
with red ship tie up erdogan the man
that has led the country for 20 years
but the mayors of Ankara and Istanbul
soon told opposition supporters their
data indicated Challenger Kamal kelich
darylu would win a tight contest
accusing State media of deliberately
prioritizing the early counting of
results that would favor the incumbent
president
erdogan's 11 years as prime minister and
nine as president have seen a wave of
modernization and growth in the country
but also a move away from secular
policies toward more traditional Islamic
values he cracked down on descent
imprisoning opponents and concentrating
power in the presidency after the failed
coup in 2016. erdogan's popularity was
dented by the two major crises in the
past year accusations of a slow response
to the February earthquakes that killed
more than 50 000 people in turkey and
his unorthodox and controversial
handling of spiraling and inflation
which peaked at 85 percent last fall
killage darylu vowed to return to more
democratic and secular values and
independent Judiciary and strengthening
ties with West his Alliance of six
parties spanned the political Spectrum
United by a desire to end the erdogan
era the third candidate and Outsider
seen on uwan heads a far-right
nationalist party
who once vote could be crucial if this
election does now go to a runoff then
his supporters could hold the balance of
power in that vote in two weeks time
Jeff all right Redmond Shannon in London
thanks red
and to Thailand now where another
pivotal election could lead to the end
of a military-backed government for the
first time in almost a decade that
country has been governed by the United
Thai nation party since 2014 when it
first seized power in a coup their
opposition the futai party was projected
to win the most seats in the lead-up to
the vote while another pro-democracy
party moved forward also saw a late
surge in polling capturing strong
support from young voters
murder mysteries coming up an
international appeal for information in
nearly two dozen cold cases
[Music]
severe weather is slamming Myanmar and
Bangladesh as Cyclone mocha makes
landfall millions are taking shelter
from heavy rainfall and powerful winds
clocking 210 kilometers an hour at least
three people have already died in
Myanmar that Cyclone also battered
Bangladesh where there are fears for the
coastal area of Cox's Bazaar a million
rohingya refugees who fled Myanmar are
camped out there early reports suggest
mocha's impact was weaker than expected
in Europe Interpol is launching an
international appeal for information in
nearly two dozen unsolved murders police
in the Netherlands Belgium and Germany
are asking for help to identify 22 women
murdered between 1976 and 2019 and whose
names remain a mystery as Mike Armstrong
explains by releasing new details about
the murders investigators hope it might
spark someone's memory
people from the neighborhood have
noticed that suitcase for weeks but
everyone thinks it is just garbage they
are 22 mysteries for each case police
have put together reconstructions and
crime scene photos this one is called
the woman in the suitcase each has a
title none has an identity the common
point between these 22 women is that
none of them have a name and that they
have likely died due to a violent Act
was she detained was she with people she
knew Nobody Knows the oldest case dates
back to 1976 called the girl in the
parking lot it was a body found in the
Netherlands by hikers in each case
Interpol is making public excerpts from
what's called a black notice information
usually shared only with police forces
suitcase these extracts would include
case information on where the body was
found and also can provide important
information on property as well as
physical descriptions including facial
reconstruction images
on June 7 2005 now the bodies were found
in three countries Belgium Germany and
the Netherlands but Interpol is reaching
out internationally it says in some
cases the victims could have been from
other countries in other cases they
could have been moved after the murder
to throw off police sadly missing
persons is a growing problem across the
world affecting all regions and this is
due for example due to global migration
as well as human trafficking
the operation casts a wide net but with
the knowledge there are answers out
there somewhere each victim had a family
and friends
someone somewhere knows Something Mike
Armstrong Global News
[Music]
still ahead a warning for women on early
screening for breast cancer
breast cancer remains a leading health
risk for Canadian women one in eight
will develop breast cancer in their
lifetime and now a U.S task force is
recommending women should be screened
sooner and more often than previously
thought as Catherine Ward explains
experts are also calling for Canada's
Health standards to follow suit
one in five breast cancers uh occurring
women in their 40s so it's very uh
common and the incidence has been
increasing in younger women the calls
from experts to lower the age for breast
cancer screening in Canada can be heard
in every corner of the country Dr Gene
Seeley is leading the chorus we have
been advocating for this in Canada for
over 10 years the importance of women
getting breast cancer in their 40s
cannot be overstated women in their 40s
have a much higher chance of having
aggressive cancer and 17 of breast
cancers happen in the 40s the debate
reignited this week after a U.S task
force echoed what experts here say they
know all too well more inclusive science
has shown us that all women should be
screened for breast cancer every other
year starting at age 40. modeling has
been done to show that upwards of uh 400
avoidable deaths are occurring in Canada
every year and so we know that lives can
be saved as with many Health standards
breast cancer screening varies between
provinces and territories but experts
say the data is clear early screening
can make a big difference especially
when lives are on the line provinces
that screen at 50 versus provinces at
screen at 40 have more cases of advanced
cancer jennydale advocates for the
change hoping to flip the narrative one
person at a time knowing what it can
mean for the patient and the people who
love them Advanced cancer doesn't just
mean death it means suffering it means
more cases of mastectomy and
chemotherapy and lymphedema and impacts
on the family not just psychological
Financial uh you know it's huge so we
have to catch cancer early and we can do
it I mean let's do it Catherine Ward
Global News Toronto
up next paying respects to Mom a
cemetery opens its doors for the first
time in months for Mother's Day
welcome back in case you forgot today is
Mother's Day with many Canadians paying
tribute to their moms including those
who have passed away one Cemetery
Canada's largest in Montreal had been
closed for months due to a labor dispute
leaving families unable to visit or even
bury their loved ones well today it
finally opened for mother's day but as
Phil Carpenter reports things didn't go
as planned
is what happens after waiting months to
see loved ones at the Notre Dame Dinesh
Cemetery
who lost his mom in February can't even
bury them it's hard enough losing your
mother but then just having her just
wait in a refrigerator for a freezer for
all these months there are nearly 300
unburied bodies according to cemetery
officials on Sunday management opened
the property for Mother's Day for six
hours so that families could visit their
loved ones I parked my car a mile away
because the doors are all closed the ad
said today was they're all going to be
open and that's not the case there's a
lot of traffic traffic lined up for at
least a kilometer in each Direction
outside the only open gate forcing
motorists to wait an hour or more just
to get onto the property it's it's
despicable I find the cemetery has been
closed since January 12 when workers
went on strike the union says management
once cut staff and freeze salaries
they've been without a contract since
2018. so for us the movie that we make
on January 12th was our Last Resort the
cemetery was opened at the end of March
for visitors to pay their respects but
it was closed again a few days later
after an ice storm brought on trees and
branches it's been closed since then
because the debris makes much of the
ground impossible some visitors Sunday
blame both parties in the dispute I
realize it's maybe the administration
but also at the same time the workers
themselves they got to like realize that
you know what they have a bigger job at
hand the Quebec government has appointed
two mediators they worked very hard and
I'm expecting new developments very soon
at the cemetery Sunday though visitors
had to take care of some things
themselves I got over 600 of dirt and
flowers from all my family my sisters my
brothers all hope for a resolution
before long Phil Carpenter Global News
Montreal
and that is global national for this
Sunday night I'm Jeff Semple and we want
to wish you a Happy Mother's Day for
many of course a bouquet of flowers is a
popular way to show mum how much she's
appreciated so tonight's your Canada is
the Atwater Market in Montreal one of
many florists seeing an uptick in
business today thanks for watching Donna
will be back here with you tomorrow have
a great night
foreign
[Music]